VALERA ZAKHAROV: Hello, welcome
to our Green At Google
and Authors At Google
Talk Series.
My name is Valera Zakharov.
And today, we have a pretty
uncomfortably exciting talk
for you today.
We have with us, a local
San Francisco-based
author, Ozzie Zehner.
And the book is called
"Green Illusions--
The Dirty Secrets of Clean
Energy and the Future of
Environmentalism." And the book
has been causing shock
waves, as "The Sunday Times"
reported recently.
And it's been pretty eye
opening actually, and
interesting to follow some of
the debates raging out there
on various internet resources.
Meanwhile, Ozzie has been
busy with his book tour.
So he's done a lot of
appearances on environmental
segments, some of which would
have been featured on CNN,
PBS, BBC, and Public Radio.
When he's not on the road, Ozzie
is a visiting scholar at
the University of California,
Berkeley, where he researches
the social, political, and
economic conditions
influencing energy policy
priorities and project outcomes.
I'm also proud to say that
Ozzie a fellow engineer.
He has an engineering degree
from Kettering University and
a graduate degree in science and
technology from University
of Amsterdam.
Before we get started, let
me do a little poll.
How many of you guys own
an electric or a
hybrid vehicle here?
So that's great, because Ozzie
is not planning to talk about
that part of the book today.
But I think it's going to
be a pretty relevant
talk to all of us.
We at Google are committed to
building a sustainable future,
both as individuals
and as a company.
And at the same time, we love
and we believe in technology.
So with that in mind, actually
Ozzie told me that he's really
looking forward to our
perspective and so he's
looking forward to your
questions and feedback at the
end of this talk.
So without taking any more time
away from that Q&A, I
would like to welcome to Google,
the author of "Green
Illusions," Ozzie Zehner.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Thank you
very much, Valera.
And thank you very much all
of you for coming today.
I really appreciate it.
And thank you for those tuning
in online as well.
I'm going to speak for about a
half an hour and then take
questions and answers.
So I know you're all very busy,
so if you want to leave
after the talk, that's fine.
If it's that bad, you can
leave during the talk.
This is not going to be a
lecture about how we must
think or how we must talk.
Rather, I'm going to consider
how we might think and talk
differently about our
energy challenges.
Now, you will all be designing
the built and conceptual
environment that we live in.
And as such, I suspect you will
be answering a lot of the
questions that I'm
struggling with.
And so the story we
will lay bare
today is far from settled.
And it really is my hope that
you will help complete it.
So let's get started.
The premise of my book, "Green
Illusions," is essentially
that green technologies are
not what they seem.
They might not be what
you think they are.
They might not be the saviors
that they're made out to be.
And I argue that alternative
energy technologies rely on a
way of legacy thinking.
But anyway, I'm getting
ahead of myself.
So I wanted to start actually
with a little
bit about my history.
I wasn't always a green energy
questioner, I guess.
It actually was just
the opposite.
And I once founded and
operated a vertically
integrated wind power operation
in Michigan, when I
was 12 years old.
And I was very stylish
at that time.
And I ran my short-lived wind
power operation out of my
parents' house.
And behind our house was a
garage, and inside that garage
was a turbine, thanks to my
dad's job at an industrial fan
manufacturer.
And I found a rusty steel pipe
to kind of use as an axle.
And I had to build a kind
of a wooden frame.
My parents had neglected to
teach me to weld, so I had to
go with wood.
And I also had not secured any
funding for a tower and so I
used a picnic table.
And then one windy day, I hauled
the contraption out,
onto the picnic table.
I lifted it up on there.
I weighed it down with bricks,
inserted the turbine assembly.
And there was very little time
to appreciate my work, because
it started spinning,
uncomfortably fast, very rapidly.
And at that point, it had become
apparent that I had
neglected to install a
braking mechanism.
So I grabbed a brick and I
shoved it against the axle.
And it was like sparking
and hissing.
And the steel sails just
effortlessly accumulated
greater speed.
And in a sense, I had created
an upended lawn mower, that
was kind of thumping with
an increasing rhythm.
And at first, the frame was
vibrating and then the whole
picnic table started
vibrating.
And really what happened
thereafter can only be deduced.
Because by that time, my
adrenaline-filled legs had
already carried me halfway
around the house.
But when I returned,
I found an empty
picnic table, in flames.
So this was the first of many
failures in my life, actually.
There was another one,
we don't have to go
through all of them.
But what I was 17, I build a
hybrid electric car, that also
ran on natural gas.
And it was not very fast.
I'm pretty sure it
was not safe.
And it got stranded in the halls
of my high school and so
forth, but not before I got a
photo op with the local paper.
And after that, I went to
engineering school.
And I worked in green tech in
Europe for several years.
And when I moved back to the
United States, I decided to
start a green architectural firm
in a historic district of
Washington, DC.
One of my first clients was a
diplomat, who wanted to live
in a solar house.
And of course, I loved
solar cells, so it
seemed like a good fit.
And he already had
the building.
It was this 100-year-old house
that had seen better days.
And about the same time the
house was built, someone had
planted two oak trees on the
western side of the house.
By the way, would anyone like to
guess why they planted the
oak trees there?
AUDIENCE: To block
solar cells.
OZZIE ZEHNER: To block solar--
this guy's thinking ahead.
AUDIENCE: Privacy.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Privacy.
I heard a lot of people
say shade.
I think you're absolutely
right, for all of these
reasons probably.
Well, actually I have no idea.
I wasn't there 100 years
ago to witness who
exactly planted the trees.
But I can guess that that
was probably the reason.
But regardless, these
trees were great.
Because they blocked
the summer sun.
And in the winter, the leaves
would fall off and they will
allow the Sun to shine through
the branches and warm the
home's exterior.
And this kind of passive solar
technology is eons old.
So as a result, the annual
utility bills for this house
were thousands of dollars less
than a house that was just
down the street that
was brand new.
And these trees had been
doing this every
year, for 100 years.
And as a green architect,
my first job was
to chop them down.
And the solar cells demanded it,
as this man pointed out.
You can't put solar cells on
the roof of a shaded house.
And I would soon find out that
this was first of many demands
that the solar cells
would make.
And demand number two, was
for lots of money.
And if you read anything about
solar cells these days, you'll
likely be left with the
impression that solar cell
costs are dropping and
the price curve looks
something like this.
But over the past decade, the
installed cost of solar cells
actually looked like this.
So why is there such
a discrepancy?
Well, part of the reason has
to do with subsidies.
Subsidies give the illusion of a
price drop, when really just
someone else is paying for it.
But there's a little bit more
to the story than that.
Journalists, for instance,
point to the price of
polysilicon and the technical
components of solar cells.
And indeed, those costs
are dropping.
But polysilicon for instance,
represents just a fifth of the
cost of an installed
solar system.
The bulk of a solar system is
low tech things like copper,
glass, aluminum, framing,
transportation, installation.
You'd still have to pay for
all of those, even if the
price of polysilicon were
to drop to zero.
And so those things get pretty
expensive, especially when you
start getting into things like
the rare earth metals and
heavy metals, which incidentally
brings us to our
next demand of solar cells, is
that they require some pretty
toxic stuff.
Now, solar cell manufacturing
involves the use or release of
numerous compounds explosive,
compounds and toxic, compounds
like the cell here, which
contains cadmium, like most
thin-film technologies, which
the EPA recognize as a toxin.
Now, what happens with this
at the end of its life?
If we incinerate this, it goes
up into the air and eventually
into the waterways.
And if we bury it, then
it can leak in
the groundwater supplies.
And not very much of this
is biodegradable.
So today, that's
not a big deal.
Solar cell generation is tiny.
In fact, the supplies is
less than 1/10 of 1%
of America's power.
If this bucket represented US
energy consumption, then this
is what the solar cell share
would look like.
Now as social production
grows, then so will the
associated side effects.
But to my dismay, the demands
of the solar cells did not
stop there.
The United Arab Emirates
recently conducted one of the
largest cross-comparison tests
of solar technologies to date.
And they did so because they
were building this
eco-metropolis called
Masdar City.
You might have heard of it.
For this test, they gathered a
whole lot of solar cells from
a lot of different
manufacturers.
And their goal was to find which
manufacturer had the
best solar cell.
But once this test begin, it
drew attention to something
else, which was the
disadvantages and limitations
that all of the solar cells
shared in common.
So a desert might seem
like the best place
to put a solar cell.
And indeed, it's one
of the best.
But there were problems.
The first was haze and humidity,
which reflect and
disperse the Sun's rays.
The next was dust, which
technicians had to scrape off
almost daily.
And in other parts of the world,
you have to deal with
pollution, hail, snow, ice,
these sorts of factors.
And the third was heat.
So right in the middle of the
day when the solar cells
should have been producing their
highest output, they got
incredibly hot, which hobbled
their output across the board.
Now, in addition
to all of these
effects, solar cells age.
And their output fades
by about 1% a year.
The newer technologies degrade
even more rapidly than that.
But an even larger surprise
awaits solar cell owners.
After about five to 10 years,
their solar array will
suddenly stop producing power.
And that's because a key
component of the solar system,
the inverter, will
eventually fail.
Now, solar cells can last
20 to 30 years,
something like that.
But inverters don't.
The inverters have to be
replaced about two to five
times during the life
of a solar system.
This is by the way, what
one looks like.
Fortunately, any electrician
can easily swap
one of these out.
But unfortunately, each
one costs about
the same as a furnace.
And incidentally, there's one
more reason I'll mention why a
solar array can stop working.
This is Glenda Hoffman's roof.
She woke up one morning to
discover that thieves stole 16
panels off her roof
as she slept.
And in fact, solar thefts are
on the rise nationally.
And the cost to replace her
system chimed in at about
$95,000, an expense that her
insurance company covered.
But nevertheless, she
intends to protect
the new panels herself.
And this is what you told
the "New York Times."
Now, a lot of people say that
these demands are worth it.
If solar power yields less CO2
than fossil fuel power, then
does this offer justification
for subsidizing solar cells?
Well, first we have
to consider costs.
Even some of the most expensive
options for dealing
with CO2 would become cost
competitive long before
today's solar technologies,
making solar cells perhaps
seem like a rather wasteful
strategy.
Why would we for instance
mitigate one ton of CO2 using
solar, when we could mitigate
five tons or 10 tons elsewhere
for the same cost?
Secondly, solar cell
manufacturing involves the use
or release of other types
of greenhouse gases.
And these are used to
make solar cells.
And they make CEO
seem harmless.
These greenhouse gases are
10,000 to 25,000 times more
potent than CO2, according
to the IPCC.
And we are now learning that
one of the fastest growing
emitters of these gases is
the solar cell industry.
So I was in the position
of having to explain
all this to my client.
And I didn't really know
where to start.
But I had to like list
off these demands.
I mean they demanded that
we retrofit the
roof, first of all.
They demanded that we purchase
lots of insurance.
The solar cells demanded
regular cleaning.
They demanded expensive
inverters
every five to 10 years.
They demanded a lot of money.
They demanded an expensive
funeral.
They demanded to be buried in
a specially sealed, toxic
waste plot.
And of course, they demanded
that those pesky trees would
have to be chopped down.
Now, think for a moment what
would you have done if you are
in my position?
What would you have advised
my client to do?
Well, here's what the
numbers looked like.
For every $100 he spent on solar
panels, he would produce
this much energy.
For every $100 that he spent
on LED lighting, he
would save this much.
The value of the trees, the
added insulation, and the
efficient appliances would
be even greater.
In the end, I advised him
against a solar cell
installation.
And instead, told him that he
should keep the trees and
spend the money on energy
efficiency and energy
reduction techniques.
And the long story short
is that I was fired.
And that's because he had
already made his decision.
The solar cells were
going to stay.
And the trees, well--
Now, my experience
was not unique.
For instance, an old grove north
of here was chopped down
to install solar cells.
And the oil company BP, chopped
down 42,000 trees
outside Brookhaven National
Laboratories for solar.
And the oil--
a company, not an oil company,
but another company in New
Jersey, took down about five
acres of trees to build a
solar array that would power a
facility to make plastic bags.
I kind of think that
puts a new spin on
paper versus plastic.
Again, we might think
it's worth it to
offset dirty coal use.
But it's important to note
that none of these solar
projects will offset the CO2
debt from clear-cutting the
forests that they sit
on, for reasons we
will come to shortly.
The solar cells also will not
replace the other benefits of
the forests, such as things
like air cleansing, water
filtration, and trails,
and other benefits.
But the fate of these trees is
ultimately a casualty of a
certain way of thinking, a
presumption that the way to
solve our energy problems is
to produce more energy.
The ethical implications of this
remind me of a movie that
I just saw last month, a classic
film, "2001, A Space
Odyssey." Has anyone here
seen the movie?
Oh, wow.
Let the record show that
almost every one
raised their hand.
So you might remember a
computer named Hal.
Hal was programmed to carry
out a certain mission.
And he followed that mission
without consideration of the
changes around him or
respect for human
life, as it turns out.
Hal thought if the astronauts
are endangering the mission,
then turn off their
life support.
If the trees are blocking
the solar cells, then
chop down the trees.
This is a kind of
mission-directed ethical trap
that we sometimes fall into
because we're human.
And that's typically because we
think we have a good idea,
a good sense of our
ethical bearings.
And our job is to apply them
to our daily life.
But as you all know, ethics can
often be more than that.
You'll recognize this
motto, I'm sure.
Now as you all know, Google
ventured into China, for
instance, to expand its mission
of bringing more
information to more people.
But in order to expand its
mission, it was required to
censor search results.
Now, Google refused to censor
the search results.
And this is a good example of
how ethical reasoning is more
than just applying our
ideals to the world.
It's more than just a mission.
It also involves looking at the
world, seeing what we can
see, and then letting
those visions
inform our ethical thoughts.
But there's a lot that
can get in the way.
For instance, when I spoke with
my client, I made the
mistake of thinking that the
facts could speak for
themselves.
I made a mistake of thinking
that my crude calculations
would be enough.
But this wasn't about
the facts.
This was about something else.
Now, we've been told that
solar cells are clean.
And we know the energy from
the Sun is limitless.
And we've been promised that
they will be cheap.
And we've been seduced
by solar cells.
And this isn't the first time
that this has happened.
For generations, our energy
bucket has been leaking.
And the leaks here represent
energy waste.
And in the United States,
most energy does nothing
productive at all.
It just leaks out, according to
the Department of Energy.
But that's not all, the leaky
bucket is also getting larger.
And that's because we
love cheap energy.
Politicians subsidize
energy production.
And when cheap energy is
available, demand of course
goes up, because people
want more of it.
And so it brings us right back
to where we started, with
so-called insufficient supply.
And this applies to alternative
energy, as well.
And in fact, there is no
evidence that alternative
energy offsets fossil fuel
use in the United States.
I know that doesn't seem
to make sense at first.
But consider the expansion of
hydropower and nuclear power.
They would both presumably
decrease coal use.
As recently as 1950 in fact,
hydropower filled a third of
the nation's electrical grid.
That's hard to imagine today.
But they did not quench
increasing demand.
And demand increased.
And the United States met that
demand by building more fossil
fuel plants, not fewer.
Today, hydropower fills just
7% of the electrical grid.
This is a boomerang effect.
The harder we throw energy
into the grid, the harder
demand comes around and
hit us on the head.
So larger solar cells and taller
wind turbines are just
ways of throwing the energy
boomerang harder.
And in fact, the history of
energy in this country is very
much a story of throwing the
energy boomerang harder.
Long ago, whale oil was
considered to be clean, cheap,
and limitless.
I mean one whale might contain
three tons of oil.
Who could want more than that?
And we poured into
the leaky bucket.
And eventually, whales
were in short supply.
And they were expensive.
But explorers had found
something better.
Their fossil fuels were cheap,
they were cleaner than whale
oil, and as any driller could
tell you, they were limitless.
But that was still not enough
for the leaky bucket.
And physicists had found
something else.
Nuclear power was clean, it was
cheap, and it was limitless.
Well, of course that
turned out not to
be the entire story.
But the bucket was still growing
and really leaking.
Which brings us to the next.
Now, there are ways to stop
the boomerang effect.
And there are ways to lower
fossil fuel demand and we'll
consider those soon.
But first I have a
few questions for
you about this bucket.
What amount of solar energy
would fill this bucket?
Will this much do it?
What if we double or triple
the solar cells
in the United States?
I mean it would be possible.
It would cost a lot of money,
but it's possible.
What if we multiply solar cells
by a 100, which would
incidentally bankrupt the
federal government.
And then we added in 10,000
utility scale wind turbines,
would that fill the bucket?
Or will it fuel the bucket's
growth and make us even more
reliant on fossil fuels?
Now, common knowledge presumes
that we have a choice between
fossil fuels and green energy.
But alternative energy
technologies rely on fossil
fuels through every stage
of their life cycle.
Most importantly, alternative
energy financing relies
ultimately on the kind of
economic growth that fossil
fuels provide.
Alternative energy technologies
rely on fossil
fuels for raw material
extraction, for fabrication,
for installation and
maintenance, for backup, as
well as decommissioning
and disposal.
And at this point there's even
a larger question, where will
we get the energy to build the
next generation of wind power
and solar cells?
Wind is renewable, but
turbines are not.
And although alternative energy
technologies rely on
fossil fuels, they
are in essence a
product of fossil fuels.
They thrive within economic
systems that are themselves
reliant on fossil fuels.
Now, I'm no fan of
fossil fuels.
Fossil fuel are finite.
They're dirty.
But we use them for five
principal reasons.
Fossil fuels our dense.
Their energy is storable,
portable, fungible, which
means they can easily
trade it.
And they are transformable
into other products, like
pesticides, fertilizers,
and plastics.
Now, these qualities cannot
be measured in kilowatts.
So what happens when we spend
our precious fossil fuels on
building alternative energy?
Well, then we get energy that
is not dense, but diffuse.
It's not easily storable.
It's not portable.
It's not fungible.
And it is nontransformable.
Now, to increase the quality of
the energy we then have to
spend more fossil fuels to
build batteries, to build
back-up power plants, and
other infrastructure.
And of course, this is
incredibly expensive.
And ultimately, that expense
represents the hidden fossil
fuels behind the scene.
Now, there's an impression that
clean energy can supply a
growing population of
high consumers.
There's an impression that
alternative energy can
displace fossil fuel use.
But the evidence doesn't
show that.
Now before I move on, I should
mention at this point in the
story, my architectural
firm is toast.
It's gone.
But luckily, I'm somewhat geeky
and willing to spend a
long time in front
of a computer.
I don't think I'm the only
person here that fits that
description.
And when gas prices rose from
2003 to 2008, they shot up.
You might remember that.
Then I stayed safely
in a library.
And as part of my academic
research, I studied a data set
of 50,000 articles that were
written over that period of
time when the energy prices
were going up.
For every doubling in oil
prices, coverage of solar wind
and biofuels shot up 400%.
But I also looked at energy
reduction strategies, things
like home insulation, light
rail, LED bulbs.
We've witnessed the impressive
pay0ff of these technologies
and so we might expect the
coverage of these technologies
to also be relatively high.
But this is what the media
coverage looked like.
And this was not just
a media phenomenon.
Does anyone recognize
this building?
It's quite a ways from here.
This is a green building in
Chicago's Millennium Park.
And to be a green building,
the architects might have
superinsulated the building,
but they didn't.
They used glass, which allows
the building to bake in the
summer and lose heat
in the winter.
They might have outfitted
the building with
energy efficient lighting.
But they didn't do
that either.
They might have incorporated
overhangs to block the high
summer Sun, but allow the
winter Sun to shine in.
Or they might have used light
shelves to toss more light
into building's interior.
But they did none of things.
This building is a green
building because
it has solar cells.
The California Academy of
Sciences, just up the road
from here, has solar cells
in one of the foggiest
microclimates on Earth.
The Chesapeake Bay Foundation
has solar cells that are
partly shaded by the
structure itself.
This BP station has solar
cells and some don't
even face the Sun.
There are solar cells right here
in Mountain View, being
consecrated in this photo.
They also don't face the Sun.
In fact, none of these buildings
has solar cells that
face the Sun.
But you see, that doesn't
really matter.
Because these architects were
not building buildings to be
energy efficient.
They were not building buildings
to reduce fossil
fuel years.
They were building temples.
They were building temples to
technology, temples to solar
energy, temples to the idea
that the way to solve our
energy problems is to
produce more energy.
Now, consider for a moment that
solar cells were a puppy.
So maybe a [INAUDIBLE], maybe
a furball like this one.
If solar cells were a puppy, I
imagine that this is kind of
what they would look like, not
real big, not real smart, but
super cute.
And we all like to take
solar for a walk.
And academics get grants for
walking solar, industry gets
good PR for walking solar,
government enjoys being out
with solar as well.
And when elections roll around,
all the more reason to
take solar out for a stroll.
And media likes to walk solar
and so does the public.
Well maybe, depending
on their political
affiliation these days.
But even I'm fascinated
by solar.
And I'm not the only person
here that is.
And sometimes being just a
puppy, solar gets tired.
But there's always someone
around to pick solar up and
keep going.
Even if it's just to walk to the
park and walk in circles.
Now, let's consider a walk
with energy reduction.
Now reduction is a huge dog,
with a lot of potential as we
have seen, although walks with
reduction, differ from walks
with solar.
Reduction's walks include many
more stops to pee, which is
made up all that more difficult
without the trees.
So why go for walks with
reduction, when the walks with
solar are so much more fun?
And that's what we need
to understand.
We need to understand and figure
out ways to organize
walks with reduction that are
more fun and interest all of
the dog walkers.
And that's going to be
a lot more exciting
than you might think.
For instance, how might
we plug the leaks
in that energy bucket?
I'd like to consider for
a moment, junk mail.
The junk mail industry claims
100 million trees a year,
which producers must grow, cut,
haul, process, print, and
then ship to homes, where they
are usually immediately thrown
away, hauled, processed,
and finally dumped.
Now, one study equates the
energy bill of the cycle to 11
coal-fired power plants running
continuously around
the clock, at full tilt.
And all of these power plants
go to power something that
most people don't even like.
So in Germany, this
is what they did.
They created this little
sticker that says no
thanks to junk mail.
And I have one right here.
And this sticker in Germany
is legally binding.
So most Germans choose
to put this stick
around their mailbox.
In the United States, these
stickers would help to patch a
small hole in our
energy bucket.
And you might think that's
no big deal.
It's just junk mail.
And in fact, it probably isn't
really that big of a deal.
But it's important to point out
that these stickers would
have a greater energy impact
than all of the nation's solar
cells, planned and existing
combined.
We don't have an
energy crisis.
We have a consumption crisis.
And a lot of that consumption
goes toward things that don't
make us any happier
or healthier.
Let's consider the growth
of that bucket.
Much of this results from
unsustainable population growth.
But how can we achieve and
ethically achieve a
sustainable population without
infringing on the reproductive
rights of individuals?
Now, we know that women who
are entitled to civil and
economic rights, who are in
control of their own bodies,
can enjoy the freedom of bearing
children at their own
rate, at a pace that
is actually
perfectly sustainable overall.
But consider this chart in
the United States showing
pregnancy and abortion rates.
Oh, so this is the population
chart of pregnancy and
abortion rates in several
countries.
A girl growing up in the United
States is four times
more likely to become
pregnant than a girl
growing up in France.
And an American girl is three
times more likely to have an
abortion than a girl growing
up in France.
And among industrialized
nations, America's teens are
the least likely to use birth
control due to stigma, lack of
health care, and high costs.
And we are now treading in
territory where environmental
and social problems converge.
And that is a vast unexplored
wilderness.
Lowering teen pregnancy rates
would greatly benefit the
nation's girls.
There's no doubt about that.
The energy and environmental
benefits could be a welcome
side effect.
So how do we stop the growth
of the bucket?
Solar cells, wind turbines,
and biofuels can't do it.
Health care and human
rights can.
And as unlikely as it may seem,
universal health care
would have a greater energy
impact than all of the
nation's solar cells, wind
turbines, biofuels, and
geothermal combined.
And it would cost less too,
a lot less in fact.
In fact, none of these proposals
cost much money.
None of these proposals leads to
lower standards of living,
just the opposite actually.
And while they are not high
tech, they rely on the same
foundations of human ingenuity
and creativity.
The real clean energy
is less energy.
But this is a shift in the way
of thinking that is not
available to many people,
because you cannot see energy
savings in the same way you
can see and even worship a
solar cell.
I set out to build
a solar house.
But what I did not initially
see, what I failed to
recognize, was that this shabby
house with its two oak
trees was already
a solar house.
Alternative energy fetishes have
so greatly consumed the
public imagination, but the
most vital, endurable
solutions go overlooked
and underfunded.
But therein lies the opportunity
for you.
You may be asked to think of
environmental solutions in
terms of energy production.
Perhaps you already have.
And when that happens, you might
be willing to think, or
ask, is that part
of the solution
or part of the problem?
If we are to understand the
ethics of alternative energy
technologies, then we must
first see what they do.
Alternative energy technologies
don't clean the air.
They don't clean the water.
They don't protect wildlife.
They don't support
human rights.
They don't improve
neighborhoods.
Alternative energy
technologies do
not strengthen democracy.
They do not regulate
themselves.
They do not reduce
consumption.
They don't reduce atmospheric
carbon dioxide.
They don't stop the leaky
bucket from growing.
Alternative energy technologies
produce power.
And we generally associate
more power with greater
prosperity.
But in fact, if we look to the
world's 10 happiest countries,
they use less energy than
Americans do, 40% less.
So these happy countries value
things like architectural
techniques that make buildings
more efficient and
comfortable.
They also prioritize walking,
biking, and public transit.
And finally, successful regions
value human rights and
health care.
In contrast, alternative energy
technologies yield low
quality energy and they
rely on fossil fuels.
They also create a host of
negative side effects.
But they don't always only rely
on fossil fuels, they are
based on fossil fuels, from
their financing, to their
decommissioning, and eventual
replacement.
Alternative energy technologies
are essentially
rebranded fossil fuels.
Now, what will people think
about alternative energy 10
years from now?
Will they think of alternative
energies as clean or will they
see them as the next round of
ecological disaster issues.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I don't claim to know
all the answers.
I'm just another member of the
search party, like you.
But it certainly seems
that there are a lot
of unanswered questions.
In fact, it actually seems
that there are a lot of
unasked questions.
And by asking the hard
questions, you will be better
prepared than anyone else to
address the rocky times ahead.
And as energy prices become more
volatile, you will have
the conceptual tools to
make a difference.
You will find your skills
to be sought after.
In fact, they will
become necessary.
It's not a question of whether
or not we have the technology
to create an alternative
energy society.
The real question
is the reverse.
Do we have a society that is
capable of being powered by
alternative energy?
And the answer today
is clearly no.
The bucket has too many leaks
and it's still growing.
But we can change that.
As the illusions surrounding
alternative energy
technologies continue to unravel
over the coming years,
you will have some
choices to make.
Will you remain rigid in
your defense of the
green legacy empire?
Will you turn off the life
support in order to protect
the illusory mission?
Or perhaps you will adapt your
thinking to the larger
challenges that we face.
Or maybe you will go beyond that
adaptation and anticipate
those challenges and be an
innovator in the next green
movement, a green movement
that is not simply a
receptacle for energy
firms and car
companies to plug into.
A green movement that looks
beyond the eco-gadgets on the
stage, to consider the social
and environmental injustices
behind the curtain.
Clean energy is less energy.
And the future of energy will
not be a story of wind
turbines, solar cells,
and biofuels.
It will be a story of livable
communities, improved
governance, health care,
and human rights.
And it is not enough to say
that we would benefit by
shifting our focus.
Our relevance, your relevance,
may very well depend on it.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First, thanks tremendously
for your talk and for
writing this book.
Google's [INAUDIBLE] energy
issues have been on the
website called The Oil Drum for
many years, where we are
commonly referring to
alternatives as fossil fuel
extenders, not replacements.
So thank you very much.
I look forward to giving your
book to other people to help
them, educate them.
But I would like to
ask a somewhat
personal energy issue.
I'm building a home right now.
We're in the rural part of
the island of Hawaii.
A grid connect is extremely
expensive,
prohibitively expensive.
And even then, the grid is like
70% naphtha burning or
something like that.
So I can do obvious things, like
LED bulbs and the like.
And in fact, the fact that I'm
choosing not to use propane
for most of my say hot water
needs, whatever, is viewed as
insane by the status quo, all
the electricians and plumbers
you might be able to
hire anywhere.
And now, my concept of using
solar for hot water, which is
limiting solar for solar
electric, has just been shot
down in flames by your
presentation.
Have you got any advice?
I'm not alone in this.
There tens of thousands
of us off grid in the
western United States.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Sure.
I'd be happy to comment on it.
Obviously, my research is in the
larger social scale and in
political context, not in
individual projects.
So I can't really make that
much of a comment on that.
But I can say that it probably
doesn't really matter.
Because if it's a vacation home
or a home on the Hawaiian
island and it's far away from
civilization and is
disconnected from the grid,
there is probably no way you
can make that green.
So I mean that's just an
unfortunate kind of reality.
I mean unless you were to move
there and sell all your
possessions and just eating the
food that falls off the
trees in your yard.
And of course, this is
the problem that
everyone runs into.
None of us can really make
our lives totally green.
And so that's why I feel that
we need to concentrate on
those ways of moving forward
that bring a lot of people and
bring a lot of interest in.
And actually when we look there,
when we start to look
and think about solutions in
those terms, we find out that
a lot of the solutions don't
really decrease living
standards and require
sacrifice.
They just require coming
back to basics.
If you were at buildings, that
might be the basics of solar
insulation and using passive
solar techniques.
And if you're considering the
larger scale, things like
health care, like I discussed
in the talk, would have
massive benefits for the
environment and for human
population.
So they are not always
against one another.
The two can work together.
And that's where we find the
sweetest opportunities.
AUDIENCE: I totally get your
point about how handling
consumption is much more
important than generation or
much more impactful.
That said, I wanted to just get
your ideas on a few things
in terms of three questions
that come to mind.
One is in terms of the solar
panel for providing energy
versus just using direct heat,
for example hot water
heating and so on.
That must be, I'd imagine, a lot
less environmentally toxic
and fairly efficient.
The second one would be, when
you use these energy efficient
things, such as fluorescent
bulbs and LED lighting, I've
been concerned about the amount
of pollution that come
from the fluorescent bulbs.
And I would assume the
LED lighting has its
own types of things.
The LEDs may last almost
forever, but I'm sure all
sorts of other things in
those lights break.
And then, that's toxic
waste, right?
So I was wondering if you'd
give guidance on that, the
solar water heating, the energy
efficient lighting.
And the third thing is the
electric vehicles.
When I look at whether to buy
a high efficiency combustion
engine versus to use something
like a hybrid electric
vehicle, I see that they have
a lot of problems with the
recycling of the batteries.
Some amount of it enters
the environment.
There's the production of it.
Or even if we consider just
holding on to your old car for
longer, if it's within emission
specs, you avoid
putting all that energy
consumption into
creating a new car.
So I've never really been
convinced that going out and
buying a new hybrid electric
vehicle is going to be a good
thing to do.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Yeah.
Thank you for those questions.
So for your first question,
solar hot water.
That's a perfect example of a
low-tech option that makes a
lot of sense in a lot
of locations.
It doesn't have a lot
of the side effects
that solar cells have.
It has side effects of its own
of course, but they're minimal
compared to the benefits
that you get.
So your second issue was with
other types of light bulbs and
energy efficiency.
And energy efficiency becomes
even an larger issue than what
you're bringing up with the
toxins in the light bulbs
themselves.
Because we have rebound effects
that occur with energy
efficiency.
As things become more efficient,
people use more of
them and it can overall
increase consumption.
So that's another side of the
energy efficiency story that I
didn't have time to talk
about today, that I
cover in the book.
And then there's the issue
of the light bulbs.
And of course, LED light bulbs
also contain all kinds of
nasty stuff and so do mercury,
compact fluorescents.
And I use LED as kind of a
comparison in my research
because in many ways they're
similar to solar cells.
They're high tech.
They were both developed
around the same period.
They were both used in
the space programs.
The were both the associated
with a lot of high-tech
industries.
And they both contain heavy
metals and toxics
and things like that.
And so there's no easy
green fix to that.
It's just weighing one set of
side effects against another
set of side effects, and that's
really difficult to do.
And this also speaks to the
electric car issue that you
talked about.
Because when we look at
electric cars, we
see the same thing.
We're used to looking for side
effects in one location, which
is basically out of
the tailpipe.
But the side effects
in an electric car
happen somewhere else.
And so it's very difficult to
see them or account for them.
And so we assume that
the electric car
is clean, of course.
But the National Academy of
Sciences did a study, a life
cycle analysis.
This is the broadest life
cycle analysis done on
electric cars.
And they found that the harms
stemming from electric cars
are a little bit larger than
the harms stemming from a
regular internal combustion
engine of a car the same size.
And in fact, the only way that
we can really find that
electric cars are cleaner, is
if we narrow our research to
just one metric, like CO2.
If we just narrow it to that one
metric, then we might be
able to make an argument that
electric cars are cleaner.
It looks like it might depend
on where they're charged and
it starts to get murky
after that.
But if we look at the whole life
cycle-- if we looked at,
like you were saying, what do
you do with the batteries
after, or how much energy is
used to get those batteries,
what are the side effects, what
are the epidemiological
impacts of the pollution.
And this is what the National
Academy has looked at.
They actually went county by
county and did epidemiological
studies and figured all that
out and accumulated it all.
And they said, you know what,
your electric cars, they run
on bullshit.
AUDIENCE: So I've been writing
about a lot of these topics
and saying many of the same
things that you did in the
first half of your talk, for a
long time, about the megawatts
and the bad math that
a lot of people do
about alternative energy.
But I've not come to the same
conclusions you have.
And I'm wondering what you use
to back up the idea that it's
likely we could conserve our
way through a crisis?
Is there any examples from
history of people doing that,
being able to solve problems
like this through conservation
and greater efficiency, rather
than what's usually happened
throughout history, which is new
technologies coming along
and changing the equations?
It's obviously difficult to
say with any accuracy what
exactly the technology of
the future will be.
But it's always incorrect to
say the technology of the
future will be the same as the
technologies of today.
And that makes this prediction
difficult.
An example of you making one
of the same mistakes you
accuse everyone else of making,
I saw on your chart,
talking about light rail as an
energy efficient technology,
light rail is the least energy
efficient per passenger mile
of technology we use
for transportation
in the United States.
It's worse than an SUV in
terms of the amount
of energy it uses.
And yet you put up as here's an
example, why aren't people
writing about this.
We make these mistakes
all the time.
But back to basically the
question is, what examples
from history can you show
of conserving to
get through a crisis?
OZZIE ZEHNER: OK, thank
you for asking that.
Well with regard to light rail,
the benefits from light
rail come in the context of the
communities that they enable.
So it's not in the light rail
itself, but it's in the
ability for people to live
in a dense urban context.
Dense urban contexts are a lot
more energy efficient, because
people with a smaller buildings,
are closer
together, they're not losing
as much energy for heat.
So you have to look at the whole
context for light rail.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OZZIE ZEHNER: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: This technology,
which means people could
deliver themselves.
They can take people
to [INAUDIBLE].
Is it really going to change
how people move in cities
[INAUDIBLE].
And nobody thinks
about it right
now as we start planning.
So it's not exactly
[INAUDIBLE].
OZZIE ZEHNER: So the future
changes of technology is
certainly something that I'm
aware of and I embrace.
I mean the technology
will change.
And we have to be prepared
for that, as well.
But ultimately, a lot of
technologies rely on energy.
And so energy becomes a road
block that's very difficult to
get through.
I just listened to a talk,
actually from Bill Gates,
where he makes this point.
And he says, energy
is not high tech.
It's not Moore's law.
Moore's law does not
apply to energy.
It's because you have to
deal with physics.
And unless you can find a way
around the physics, you're
still left with any technology,
any growth in
society, any growth physical--
from a physical perspective--
is going to have to be
powered in some way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
OZZIE ZEHNER: Yes.
And so of course, Gate's
solution is to have the
nuclear reactor.
Exactly.
So the problem is you either
have to believe that infinite
growth is sustainable over the
long term, an infinitely
growing population is
sustainable the long term, or
we can look to what examples are
there of dealing with the
whole issue with conservation?
And there really are no good
large-scale examples of that.
I mean we're watching it happen
with Japan right now,
which is probably the
place to look.
And one of the other speakers
that was here at Google, James
Howard Kunstler, I was recently
on a blog cast with
him in which he mentioned
something really curious.
And he said, he thinks that--
I says all kinds of
fascinating things
that make me think--
and he said Japan is basically
going back to a craft society.
He uses this kind of a thought
experiment to say, look what's
happening in Japan.
Their population is rapidly
decreasing and they're
changing their societies in ways
that have never been done
in advanced industrial
societies before.
And so I think we can maybe look
to countries like that
and see what might be happening
and what might come
several decades down
the future.
But no, you're right.
There's no good for it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for speaking.
I think your points about
reducing consumption are very
interesting.
But it was interesting because
almost every single statement
you made in your talk, I wanted
to ask a follow-up
question to it, to understand
better, which was provoking.
The one that I think is perhaps
the most important to
me to clarify at the moment, you
said a lot about how green
technology and alternative
energies, like solar panels,
require fossil fuels to build
and deploy and recycle.
And do they require fossil fuels
per se or do they just
require energy?
Like if we had hydro and solar,
you could presumably
just take the same electricity
and build
the plants with those.
They don't logically
require coal.
We just don't have enough
existing infrastructure yet.
Am I right?
Or are you saying something
that I didn't understand?
OZZIE ZEHNER: No, that's
a really good point.
And this is another big question
that I can't fully
answer because in a way, in many
ways, it's unanswerable
about what might happen
in the future.
We need the energy.
Yes, you're right.
The problem is that certain
types of industries rely on
certain types of energy.
So it's difficult to explore
for copper and bring the
trucks out there, if they are
only running on electricity.
So that's why we use the
fossil fuels for that.
And so the cost ends up going up
significantly if you try to
replace certain types of energy
for other types of
energy in different contexts.
But yeah, ultimately
it's the energy.
But there's also qualities
to energy that go beyond
kilowatts or the amount of
energy, like I brought up the
fungibility and the storability
and the transport.
And so these are all qualities
that we have to keep in the
back of mind.
And it's difficult to really
put those in a spreadsheet,
because how do you measure those
and how do you compare
them across different
energy technologies.
AUDIENCE: So let's say you're
declared the dictator of the
United States tomorrow.
OZZIE ZEHNER: It would be a sad
day for the United States.
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's
a better goal.
Or the world, whatever
your prefer.
What changes would you make to
the existing system, let's say
policy changes or something like
that, to make people move
in the right direction?
So for example, like let's say
removing the subsidies and
making technologies reflect
what they truly cost
throughout their life cycle,
might be something.
But you show that it doesn't
work, because solar panels
really aren't as effective as
just reducing your usage.
So what kind of changes
would you make, if
you were the dictator?
OZZIE ZEHNER: Whew, well--
AUDIENCE: Sorry, loaded.
OZZIE ZEHNER: First of all,
there would be Lucky Charms in
all of the restaurants.
I think probably universal
health care would be the
number one priority.
I feel like universal health
care has so many benefits.
And we often hear people say oh,
I don't really want to pay
for that person's health care.
And it's just like that person
is going to go to
the doctor too much.
Well, first of all that kind of
like a remarkable breakdown
in civil society.
It represents a kind of
remarkable drawback from that
perspective.
But also, most people don't
recognize that we already have
an emergency universal
health care system
in the United States.
When a homeless person goes
into the ER with pneumonia
because they didn't have health
care, they end up
spending a lot of money
on bringing that
person back to health.
And of course, that system
is incredibly expensive.
And that's why we could actually
save money by going
to something like a universal
health care system, like the
ones in Europe.
And there's nothing
about the health
care systems in Europe--
they're not perfect, I guess
is what I'm trying to say.
But you also don't see Germans
in the streets protesting for
an American style health
care system.
And I think that's something we
have to keep in mind too,
in all the rhetoric going back
and forth on these issues.
The other things that I would
enable, to make a short list,
is a kind of energy efficiency
enabling
technology or research--
a Department of Efficiency
instead of a
Department of Energy.
And also things like removing
zoning restrictions that
prevent density in certain
urban contexts can end up
having a big impact.
And so that's probably the
direction I would do.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Ozzie--
OZZIE ZEHNER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: --thanks a lot for
your wonderful talk.
I really enjoyed most of the
talk, especially the fact that
you've taken such a radical
approach to what the
common belief is.
And you're being successful in
conveying the point, which is
very scientific and
well-grounded.
So I really appreciated the
point that you mentioned the
real crisis is a crisis of
consumption, not the
production.
However after that, I didn't
quite follow how you link that
to the population management.
About that, just from what you
said, I would like to share,
like for India as country, the
population has been mostly
huge for thousands of years.
And I usually read a lot of
Sanskrit literature from
ancient stories, like ancient
history of India.
It's been a vast population
all the time.
And it's been sustaining.
All the problems that you
mention having to do with
electricity and fossil fuels,
that all started like in only
the last 100 years or so.
But prior to that danger,
civilization has been running
for years and years and years
without any of these problems.
So I'd just like to point out
that it's not necessarily the
population.
But it's under a dimension that
I would like to just kind
of hint at here, which you
might be interested in
pursuing for further, which
is actually the concept of
consciousness, like
who we really are.
What bring satisfaction to us as
a person, as a individual.
So the Indian culture is kind
of focused on that spiritual
dimension, which provides the
higher level of satisfaction
so that you don't depend
on gadgets and material
technology to fulfill your
demands constantly.
Which is what that the vast
majority of the consumption
comes from.
So without providing an
ultimate higher way of
enjoying your life, you cannot
really take away all the
gadgets and say that
be [INAUDIBLE]
and solve the energy
problem that way.
Rather, the Indian culture is
focused on the aspect that
you're a spiritual being and you
can be satisfied by other
means spiritually, compared
to you using gadgets.
That's one of the main reasons
that civilization has
sustained for so many years.
So I'd just like to comment on
that and see if you have any
thoughts about that?
OZZIE ZEHNER: Well, I should
make a clarification that
probably our views are not
incongruent, in that I'm not
for population control.
I should say that right
off the bat.
In fact, I think the idea of
population control within the
environmental movement, and
there are some people pushing
for population control,
and I think
that's a misguided effort.
And that's because I do think it
tramples on the ability for
societies and for individuals
to have a free life and
procreate how they choose to.
But we find that actually
coercion is not
necessary at all.
If you look in China, the lowest
birth rate is in a
place where the one-child
policy does not
apply, in Hong Kong.
And we find that throughout
the world.
Actually Shanghai, also.
It doesn't apply and Shanghai
also has a low birth rate.
We find that really by just
instituting human rights and
health care, it allows people to
have the number of children
that they want to have.
And that number happens
to be sustainable
over the long term.
And so really the trick I think
is just delivering human
rights and health care
in the first place.
I really see population growth
as a symptom of suboptimal
social conditions.
So the real thing to do is to
just satisfy those social
conditions and the population
growth will
take care of itself.
AUDIENCE: I have one
other question.
I think we're getting
low on time.
But I was curious what you
thought of the work of like
Professor Jacobson at Stanford,
and others, who have
come out and said, look, we have
the technology, we have
the resources to power all of
the energy in the world today
with existing known
technology, for
wind, water, and solar.
And how you compare that with
your graphs of showing the
tiny drops compared to
very large buckets?
Do you think his analysis is
wrong or do you agree with it
and were presenting something
different?
OZZIE ZEHNER: I was actually
just on a radio show, NPR,
last week, and he
was on the show.
And the issue with this report
which you're referring to, for
people who don't know, is that
basically there's these ideas
that there's enough solar energy
in the Mojave Desert to
power the entire world.
There's enough wind power to
power 100 times what we need
and these kinds of things.
And really, these are
just a failure
in the way of thinking.
I mean of course if you ask a
ridiculous question, you can
find a ridiculous answer.
And I mean the Mojave
Desert may be the
Saudi Arabia of solar.
But if we were to cover it with
solar cells, and cover
the world's deserts with solar
cells, it would destroy
civilization as we know it
within a single generation,
just because of the toxins, the
fossil fuels that would be
required, the other climate
gases that are produced, that
are many times worse than CO2.
If you take that little dot of
solar energy that we get
currently, or wind power that
we get currently, and then
multiply those side effects by
something like 10,000, that's
what you're looking at.
So you just get another set of
side effects with alternative
energy technologies.
And they all rely
on fossil fuels.
Thermal solar has the
same side effects.
When you get back down to it,
you end up with the same types
of side effects.
The high cost of thermal solar
reflects the fossil fuels that
are behind the stage.
AUDIENCE: So is it accurate to
say that you think in that
report, they didn't do a proper
life cycle analysis?
OZZIE ZEHNER: I don't think they
asked the right question.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Yeah, that's
what I don't think.
I mean maybe their findings
are correct.
I could ask the question, how
many threads of linen are in
this carpet.
And I might be able
to find an answer.
But is that really a meaningful
question to be asking?
AUDIENCE: In a Google
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Thank you.
Great talk.
I'm not as well read as some
of the other questioners.
But I'm curious why nuclear is
not mentioned anywhere and
whether you think that there's
a place for it
in the future world?
Thank you.
OZZIE ZEHNER: Thank
you for asking.
That's an excellent question
about nuclear.
A nuclear would be a whole
series of talks,
aside from this one.
Which is why I didn't
talk about it here.
I do talk about it
in the book.
So if you're interested in my
views on nuclear power, you
can look there.
But nuclear is a fascinating
case because it is something
that is actually scalable and
there is a lot of fissionable
material on the planet.
And that can be looked at as
a blessing or a curse.
And there's people that look
at it from both directions.
The issue with nuclear power
is that we have yet another
set of side effects and
limitations and consequences.
Some of them, we
know very well.
Some of them are risky
situations, that are growing
and accumulating over time,
such as that with waste
disposal and access
to proliferating
materials like plutonium.
And the nuclear armaments
industry has even tested
byproducts from the thorium
cycle in anticipation that
there might be a thorium
push in the future.
So we will look at conflict.
We look at potential for
materials getting diverted.
We look at long term storage
of nuclear waste.
We look at the potential
for explosions or
like Fukushima disasters.
And so, we just get another
set of side
effects with nuclear.
But the big issue with nuclear
that shouldn't be
underestimated is that there
is a lot of fissionable
material on the planet.
And we're going to run into
different types of barriers
with nuclear than we're
encountering with fossil fuels.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
OZZIE ZEHNER: Oh, I'm not the
right person to ask about
either projects and the fusion
reactors and things like that.
Fusion has been kind of 30 years
in the future now, for
very long time.
But we're now kind of finding
that the future isn't what it
used to be.
And it's getting more and more
difficult to really see a way
forward with things
like fusion.
I mean maybe it will
happen some day.
I don't really know.
Thank you very much.